[Music]
deer creek international business
solutions how can i help you i am ready
well that's great ladybug ladybug your
new operational name oh i see what
you're doing ladybug's supposed to be
lucky
you don't have bad luck
really
my bad luck is biblical i'm not even
trying to kill people when someone dies
remember the suicidal bell boy you drove
him to the hospital hang in there buddy
and he didn't die okay the wedding
tequila
johannesburg
it's time for some change you want it
simple for your first job back it
doesn't get simpler
[Music]
we need to find the person who took that
case
[Music]
that's too easy
[ __ ] what remember those two wackos from
the bolivia jobs the twins yeah no sure
they're twins get off the train
[Music]
you don't remember me you look like
every white homeless man i've ever seen
really you don't remember me
oops he's a pack of dicks lady i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm i'm working on it get off
at the next stop sounds so easy when you
say it one little prick from this you
know what happens yes your blood
congeals
i said yes
you're going to want to hear the whole
story that's reinforcing here the white
death with his army of assassins there's
this soulless psychotic leader with the
largest criminal organization on the
planet shoved right inside
i don't see the white death letting any
of us off this train
we need to come up with a plan
[Music]
what's happening to your face maybe
there was a little head trauma
[Music]
i i gotta get off this train
[Music]
sorry
exclusively in buddy theaters
[Music]
you